terminant son voyage en amérique du sud
général de gaulle est entré ce matin
dans la baie de rio
rio c'est le brésil seize fois grand
comme la france
le voyageur non avertis qui débarque au
brésil à la surprise de constater que
tout ce qu'il mange tout ce qu'il boit
les véhicules qui l'empruntent sont
fabriqués au brésil
do brasil c'est à dire du brésil fait au
brésil do brasil ces deux mots que l'on
retrouve à tous les coins de rue sont
l'expression jalouse d'un
protectionnisme d'un nationalisme
économique qui a abouti à la création
d'une industrie proprement brésilienne
dans ce grand magasin de rioz jenner qui
fut lancée par des français 95 % des
articles sont sinon de conception du
moins de fabrication brésilienne
c'est principalement dans le domaine des
réalisations industrielles que la france
a contribué
de l'économie brésilienne
certains nous ont dit que les industries
sucrières françaises furent les
premières à s'installer dans ce pays
d'autres affirment que ce sont les
industries pharmaceutiques quoi qu'il en
soit nous avons effectivement construit
outre-atlantique des laboratoires des
plus modernes qui sous une direction
française avec un personnel brésilien de
mettre en boîte flacons des médicaments
dans les formules ont été conçus dans la
banlieue parisienne où la région
lyonnaise
non loin du port de santos que vous
voyez ici émergé en plein mois d'août
des brumes de l'hiver pousse le complexe
sidérurgique de lagausie pas qui sera
demain le plus vaste d'amérique du sud
et dans la construction duquel les
industries françaises sont majoritaires
suivi de près par les allemands et les
italiens
plantes des industries nord américaine
affrontant l'instabilité financière à
l'affût des grandes commandes de l'état
des usines de mécanique lourde ont été
édifiés par la france au brésil celle ci
par exemple qui a surgi dans la campagne
près de la petite ville de tao pacte est
sur la route de rioz assane fall
c'est alpha vous êtes directeur d'une
usine d'une usine que l'on peut dire
françaises oui entièrement française de
conception est actuellement si pas tout
à fait mais jusqu'à cette année ils
étaient entièrement française autres
usines sa pelle mécanique à sézanne
c'est à dire mécanique lourde que
fabriquer vous exactement des
équipements pour toute l'industrie de
base du pays c'est à dire principalement
usines hydroélectriques équipements pour
la sidérurgie
machines à papier aux fourneaux
moteur diesel marin et vous travaillez
pour qui nous avons des clients aussi
bien dans l'industrie privée que les
industries contrôlée par l'état par
exemple cette pièce que je vois ici pour
qui étaient ces deux pièces sont
destinés aux barrages du poupon gars qui
est une entreprise
brésilienne
construit qui construit actuellement le
plus gros barrages amérique du sud pour
un coupon gars nous avons en commande 37
de ses vannes qui ont un point unitaire
d'environ 80 ans a travaillé avec des
fournitures brésilienne et pour le
brésil c'est dire que votre usine est
complètement coupée de l'économie
française
l'usiné est autonome elle travaille avec
des moyens locaux en hommes et en
matériel et en matières premières
suffisant pour lui permettre de faire
les fabrications qui lui sont confiées
mais elle reçoit de ses
commanditaire notamment des usines
françaises une technique très
appréciable et indispensables
surtout dans la banlieue de la
bouillonnante cité d'affaires de sao
paulo que se forgent le fer de lance de
l'économie brésilienne non loin de ses
gratte ciel dont quelques-uns sont
l'oeuvre de l'architecte français
jacques pilon une réussite qui fait
l'admiration des spécialistes cette
entreprise française qui est venu lancer
sur le marché brésilien des produits
chimiques et de la matière première pour
l'industrie textile et cela sous un
prétexte apparemment assez futile tu
vois que vous me parliez d'abord de
l'implantation de votre maison ici au
brésil c'est grâce au carnaval qui notre
maison s'est installé au brésil le
premier atelier qui a été démontée et
l'a été pour la fabrication des lances
parfum le lan ce parfum est constitué
par un tube métallique rempli d'un
produit chimique parfumé et qui pendant
le carnaval servait arroser ses voisins
leur produisant une sensation de froid
assez désagréable c'est désagréable en
face à remplacer les confettis ou
apparent pour le lire naval de rio a
remplacé les confitures et c'est ainsi
c'est pour fabriquer selon ce parfum que
votre maison est venu ici exactement et
où en êtes vous aujourd'hui
depuis cette fabrication de lens parfum
l'usiné agrandie et fabriquer des
produits chimiques et des produits pour
l'industrie textile vous avez combien
d'usinés exactement nous avons à santo
andré trois usines une à saint josé dos
campos et une à campinas wii et qui
occupe combien d'ouvriers au total
environ dix mille ouvriers n'allait pas
aujourd'hui a regretté l'histoire d'une
ans partira pas du tout monsieur dubois
comme nombre de français installés au
brésil depuis plusieurs décades ne sait
plus très bien aujourd'hui s'il est plus
français que brésiliens ou inversement
les simca
chambord ou présidente et les plus
luxueuses des voitures brésilienne ne
conserve l de français qu'en ligne
élégante elle le sortent aussi ajoutons
le dessert puissantes de ces machines
venues tout droit de poissy
quant aux voitures renault elle non plus
l de français qu'une seule pièce le
distributeur le dcau s'il envers vous
représentez les usines renault ici au
brésil comment les usines renault sont
elles installées ici et bien la
direction générale de la régie renault a
en effet pris la décision en 1958 de
céder une licence de fabrication à une
société établie sur place
que reste-t-il de français dans une
voiture comme celle ci dans une gordini
et bien l'idée la conception est
naturellement française mais
le véhicule lui-même par ces pièces est
complètement brésilien puisque lundi
nationalisation emploi atteint
99,3 course alors quel est l'intérêt
pour les îles renault d'être au brésil
eh bien d'abord il s'agit d'implanter la
marque dans un pays étranger et les
importations étant fermés pour les
véhicules construits il fallait donc le
monte ou le fabriquer sur place
par ailleurs il ya un produit financier
naturellement qui est séduite les
redevances payées sur un véhicule
fabriqué sous licence
ainsi que dix ans les dividendes
qui sont reçus par la régie renault en
échange de l'apport l'investissement
initial qui était de 6 millions de
dollars auraient l'art nous avons
affaire ici sur le disputer la chaussée
brésilienne entre autres à volkswagen eh
bien nous sommes naturellement plusieurs
sur la place je suis persuadé qu'il y a
ma foi de quoi satisfaire tout le monde
et nous nous y employons la présence au
brésil de toutes ces industries très
diverse stimule évidemment les échanges
commerciaux dans la mesure où la
stabilité politique et partant
financière créé un climat de confiance
le marché le plus intéressant passé ces
dernières années entre la france et le
brésil contre la france et plusieurs
pays d'amérique du sud d'ailleurs
rappelait aux anciens l'épopée de la
ligne karavel est partie elle aussi de
toulouse pour aller sous le nom rêver de
causèrent do sul croix-du-sud parcourir
les espaces brésilien à sa mesure pour
vous représentants de caravelle sur
l'amérique du sud sans être un prise
d'un plaisir de représenter un article
comme caravelle non oui c'est exact
c'est vraiment un avion qui ce qui si
nous a donné toute satisfaction sur le
réseau brésilien et amérique du sud par
les distances d'une part qu'il permet de
couvrir par la simplicité de maintenance
et surtout par son confort et
actuellement on a l'impression que c'est
vraiment l'avion le plus
le plus aimé des passagers est-ce que
les caravelles ont ici à couvrir des
itinéraires plus difficile que sur
l'europe par exemple dans certains cas
où ils les étapes sont plus longues
précisément cette étape que va faire le
commandant de brasilia manaus est une
étape qui en europe représenterait déjà
un des maximums voyez un des maximes la
ripisylve réelles sur des étapes très
longue mais sans difficulté tout va très
bien
[Musique]
nous allons abandonner ce cours de
littérature française nous allons
laisser beaumarchais pour quelques dents
car je crois que la radio télévision
française va vous poser une question
pour quelle raison étudiez vous français
cela se rapporte à mon enfance quand
j'étais petite ma mère m'a toujours
raconter des histoires des enfants de
france cela m'a toujours attiré mon
attention vers la france le pari le
peuple la stabilisation
j'ai commencé à étudier le français
obligés père mes parents et bien vite la
douceur et la musicalité de cette langue
m'ont attrapé aujourd'hui j'espère
obtenir une bourse d'études à paris pour
pouvoir continuer à connaître les
auteurs et la littérature française
j'apprends le français parce que je veux
être diplomate je pense que malgré
l'extrême influence de la langue
anglaise dans le monde j'ai la langue
française continue toujours à être la
langue de la diplomatie mondiale savez
j'aime beaucoup les phrases et je me
tairai de toutes ces cultures de la
littérature au chant sonel j'adore le
charme pittoresque français et je vais
même faire un cours de littérature
contemporaine à paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous les pays industrialisés et en
premier lieu les états unis ont posé
leur carte au brésil qui étant donné son
immensité et ses ressources
considérables se réserve l'avenir
prodigieux
[Musique]